[Music]
so i was unloading head i just found
this dog
hey baby well never a dull day at the
farm
it's a dog party in bed
good morning everyone say good morning
delaila
that's where we are saying good morning
i am taking you guys along
my whole day you guys have asked what do
i do and what my life is like
uh every morning i wake up around seven
in the morning
with these two delilah and benelli who's
begging for my food as if it's gonna
fall
on the counter they already ate their
breakfast i took them on a walk it's
about 7 30 here now
now after since i've just got done
making my coffee
and all that fun stuff i'm going to get
dressed
and then head to the farm because we all
know
i don't live at the farm i live about 20
minutes away from there
so let's get this day started and you
guys are able to come along and see what
my life is like
good morning do you say every morning i
go out on the patio and i bark at the
neighbors
but nelly begs for my breakfast and
sometimes delilah actually reaches it
so she'll probably push it back and
she'll steal my breakfast
and share with benelli sometimes
and going back out to the patio
we're following mommy to get dressed
come on now
but now he swears that the food's gonna
fall for her look
as if a ghost is magically gonna push
the food down and she's gonna be able to
eat it
come on now 20 minutes later still
trying to get my sandwich
no benelli it has ham in it now they're
both begging great i just got in the car
i had to literally move all these bags
of green
and cat food from that vehicle to this
vehicle and load all this stuff in here
into this vehicle from that vehicle so
that took me a little bit
and it is freezing here i know you guys
are going to say it's not that cold but
in florida we're not used to this
weather it's 41 degrees here
but let's go to the farm this is my
favorite
part getting stuck behind tractors
this is like the mile road the six mile
road to
the farm there's a little bunny
walking into the gate i have to open the
gate to pull the truck
the sun's so bright but we're here at
the farm i'm going to unload
all the stuff i have in the truck the
first
part of my day even though i just
unloaded my last vehicle
i have to reload unload this one
oh my gosh guys look a little baby bunny
is hiding behind this bush
let me see if i can catch it for all the
tater fans there's tater bunny
look at this little black baby i'm cute
no way it's way too fast
but i know everyone loves look how cute
that is oh my gosh
how adorable for all the tater
fans everyone that loves the tater bunny
he's right there
there's bp and
oreo and then look how cute is that
though
oh tater's definitely like the king
of all the bunnies he bosses everyone
around
and then we have some new babies down
here let's see there's the mama
i actually did put a bunny in a stall
last night
because she looked a little sad
which i'm probably gonna end up taking
her home she's actually super sweet
i just felt like she wasn't getting
enough attention hi baby look how sweet
she is
remember how i told you guys the jobs
never end well this water line
hose snapped i would turn on but i would
get sprayed with water and i don't want
to be wet all day
so i have to redo this the crack is like
right here
but if i was to turn it on it would
literally go all over me so i have to
replace this water line
i mean obviously you guys can see i've
replaced it plenty of times
and then kind of a lazy job so i'm going
to
fix it the right way today but first
i have to turn the well off so the water
doesn't go everywhere when i
snip the line so the well is up here
in this pasture and to turn it off
you're gonna go like this
it's off so what i'm gonna do is snip it
down here i hope i don't get super
water on me
cool
[Music]
what i just realized is that i could
save this piece
so i'm going to make it like this
so i thought this little twisty thing
was cool i mean i could do it short but
i'm gonna make a longer one
so i need a cup link
which is right here this one will work
i hate this glue it gets everywhere and
it sucks when it gets on you
so what we're going to do is we're going
to cut link this
try not to get it on you because it
sucks getting it off
one part done i like to use a lot of
glow so it stays
if you all can't tell okay cool
great and what i need to do is now
cut another pvc pipe up here to adapt
to this part i'm like the messiest
worker ever when it comes to doing this
stuff
at least i try to measure
so we'll go ahead and do this part first
and get more glue all over me why
katrina
why are you so messy when you do this
stuff it never fails i'm literally
always covered in this stuff
but acetone takes it off so let's go
like this
whoop
okay cool but guys check out this water
line compared to the new one
i would say it looks pretty good what i
have to do still is
take my drill and then just click it on
here so the horses don't play with it
because the horses love to
break these apparently especially during
the winter time the pipes freeze all the
time and look damn's probably on his way
over here to mess it up
so i do do pretty much all the water
line fixes
on the farm i actually was
here digging all the water lines with
the guys that dug them here
so i can learn how to do it if we ever
did have a break because that's part of
owing a farm
shut the front door did i not fix it
properly
i was like tell me i didn't tell me i
fixed it right
and i realized it was coming from here
so i did good job katrina
go waterline girl tilly decided to join
me
and keep me company i'm jumping over oh
my gosh don't fall don't fall
okay so i could fill this water drop up
and the water line is fixed me and
jackie were just talking about there are
so
many bunnies here at the farm i
literally just like came over here
and walked under the pergola and there's
like 20 babies
like there are so many bunnies we
literally had like no bunnies
like three months ago and today we have
a zillion look at little bam running
around
he's so cute
literally just look at him he's been
like scratching himself
he's so funny oh my gosh bam
your personality boy is hilarious
jackie goes i'm really starting to like
these shavens but every time
this drips where does it drop it drops
see it's like in the cracks
it drops oh my god you should try my
forehead
you're in the right spot so so far i've
fixed water lines unloaded horse grain
gave a cat medicine which i didn't
record um now i have to
deworm all the horses go pick up horse
hay
do a couple more things drill in some
boards at the horses broke
but my day has been already kind of long
and i still it's only ten o'clock so i
have a lot more stuff to do
so hang tight and let's go go jackie
dance
all right now that i have all my errands
at the farm done i'm running to go get
horse hay
for the horses i have to get peanut hay
and tifton hay
for in the barn which are bails that we
give in the stalls at night time when
the horses are turned in or when the
horses are turned during the day
so let's go to circle h check it out i
have to unload all this hay
by myself it's 12 bales we feed a tifton
and peanut hay here they each the horses
that are in the stalls get a flake of
each it's gonna be fun
[Music]
whose dog is that hi buddy so i was on
loading head i just found this dog
hi mama you friendly
come here there's two of them come here
guys
do you got a caller come on
here let's go open doc saw let's find
open the docks out let's put them in
there
come on mama come here hi baby
well never a dull day at the farm okay
this one has a color
come on baby come in here come on come
on let's give him some water
you all want some water well as you guys
can see
while i was unloading hay two dogs were
at the farm
i don't know whose they are but we're
gonna keep them here in the salt so we
find the owners
and make sure they go back home right
guys
okay they look well fed one has a collar
but no tags so
i'll go to like the local gainesville
pet finder and um
try to find where their owners are well
while we look for the owners for these
puppies
i'm gonna go back to doing the hay but
they're in a stall right now and they're
gonna be fine
and we're gonna find you guys these
homes okay your food and water though
all right all right sweetie
[Music]
well now that i'm done unloading hay and
just found two dogs
i am hanging out here i just posted the
dogs on like the local gainesville pet
finder
and gainesville word of mouth so
hopefully their owners come back
and i'm just hanging out here right now
until
i can catch my breath and then i have to
go run some more errands
so it never ends never ends
where am i handsome am i handsome are
you still mad at me for do you worming
you today
yeah maybe not did you see the dogs
did you guys see the dogs what were they
doing what were they doing bammy
ew you literally just dropped like snot
on my hand gross
hi babies
farm errands never stop i'm making
jackie come with me to go get
j bangs up in lake city which is an hour
drive
the reason why i go up there to get
shavings is because it saves a lot of
money
and i don't want this guy to waste his
wood shavings so i go and pick them up
once a month
and we are headed that way now
remembered
well jackie reminded me that i have to
run in and grab garbage bags
from home depot because that is one
thing i do bring for the guys so he
doesn't have to
buy because he's already giving me
shavings so i'm in here
at home depot looking for garbage drugs
and where are they
we're in action lake city we're coming
for you
[Music]
farm stuff never ends
hold up here and i was like jack you
just move the truck if someone comes and
yells at you
because i'll be two seconds wow
all right garbage bags
we're ready get all these shavings i
don't have to
go in the truck got
all the bags loaded up with shavings
hello jackson you did a good job loading
them up
i did so
jackie's recording us jackie say hi hi
we got the shavings loaded up oh god
jackie terrible ankle
wait what this ring
okay jackie if you pull it like it's
like look
look i don't want that double chin up in
there
okay so we got the shavings loaded we're
driving back
and we just stopped to get some snacks
as we were starving
right yep what'd you get i got
a six dollar cheeseburger i got jackie
you get that from mcdonald's for like a
dollar
it's really good though mine's a little
hard but
it's good i got two red bulls and i
already ate i got like this like buffalo
chicken thing we're gonna head into the
farm
i'm making jackie run some errands with
me because i love her company
but let's go to the farm now to unload
the shavings and then what are we doing
and then we're gonna paint it and then
we're gonna ride
yeah thumbs up thumbs up subscribe you
know subscribe
thumbs up well guys all the shadings go
here as you guys can
tell we are running low on them we do
buy bags of shavings as well as we pick
them up
so i'm just gonna go and unload the
shavings and start putting them here
my god
i hope you all enjoyed part one of my
video because there are two parts to
this video
and i have so much more left to do at
the farm look out for the second one
because
like i said we have so much to do and
there's money as always they're
everywhere on this farm but you guys
stay tuned for it
[Music]
you